last week's indictments against more
than a dozen Russian individuals and
organizations are increasing concerns
about the safety and integrity of this
fall's midterm elections
tonight correspondent Peter Doocy looks
at some of the biggest vulnerabilities
and what is being done about them to
figure out how to stop Moscow from
meddling in the midterms dozens of
secretaries of state spent a long
weekend in Washington for meetings that
started with a peek at Putin's playbook
in the latest Muller indictment that was
a million dollar a month operation so
that gives me an idea of the resources
that were working against most of that
money went towards propaganda the
biggest threat seems to be from the
American public believing the many false
stories that were told out there during
the last election but voting systems are
vulnerable to 21 states were targeted by
Russian hackers in 2016 and many
networks are still flawed the endpoint
security on most of those electoral
systems is outdated and it can't match
up to the modern-day weaponry being
created by the Russian cyber adversaries
during the 2016 cycle the FBI felt the
system was safe because it is so spread
out the beauty of the American voting
system is that it is dispersed among the
50 states and it's clunky as heck it's
not exactly a swift part of the internet
of things but things have changed now
that more precincts have Wi-Fi what's
happened is as the states have evolved
with their use of technology to
facilitate voting to increase the number
of voters to improve the process of
voting they've expanded the attack
surface that can now be penetrated by
foreign adversaries this weekend to
classified briefings were held for
election officials from every state the
Office of the Director of National
Intelligence says the sessions were all
about quote increasing awareness of
foreign adversary intent and
capabilities against the state's
election infrastructure as well as a
discussion of threat mitigation efforts
a DHS official tells FOX News that right
now 32 states and 31 local governments
are receiving remotely operated cyber
hygiene scans for vulnerabilities and 14
states have requested on-site risk and
vulnerability assessments which won't be
done till mid-april
but the DHS secretary Kirsten Nielsen is
telling state officials it still
ultimately up to
to keep elections secure she has
absolutely no desire or no intention to
take over elections and to run elections
from the federal level down to the state
level that was the thing we were the
most enthusiastic about hearing from
secretary Nielsen the first primaries of
the 2018 cycle are two weeks from
tomorrow so there is a great sense of
urgency to beef up cyber defenses even
though there is still no publicly
available evidence to show that Russia
or anybody ever hacked a polling place
in 2016 to change a ballot John why they
got a big task ahead of them Peter no
question about that